chassé kid is fun jazz is great for the
brain it's also fun to play and chess
kid makes it easy to have fun whether
your child is a total beginner or a
prodigy they can hop on and find a well
matched opponent from around the world
at any time chess kid is the safe parent
approved way for your child to play
chess online chess kit is educational to
kids it feels just like playing the
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to mastery
this curriculum is designed to work with
global educational guidelines there are
more than 50 thousand chess puzzles and
a whole library of entertaining videos
that teach strategies tactics openings
and end games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds chess kid helps you organize
your students and monitor their progress
each child receives a weekly report card
that shows how many lessons puzzles and
gains are completed you can also
organize kids into clubs and send the
messages chess kid is the online home of
scholastic chess for thousands of kids
parents schools and coaches signing up
is free and easy so what are you waiting
for
you